[Music]
hello and happy Wednesday or Thursday or
whatever because we are on demand Sims a
left go what is good Sims how are you
I'm good how are you Adam left what is
on your brain today for episode 150 I
don't know I'm just here to talk
football in here to come meet the
producers bleacher department is Mary's
Josh [ __ ] Josh josh is some how about
that I'm starting off the podcast with
that Joshua they have 14 words today on
the podcast federal do what to do we are
gonna get into of course our favorite
coach the NFL Kyle Shanahan we're gonna
get into Michael Bennet's comments we're
gonna have Phil big big Phil orthopod
and I have some random questions for you
and we're gonna dive a little bit in the
Sims is draft and notebook grab no book
I had something happen to be on the
train today that I'd like Chris because
you don't take the subway yeah you take
the train right where everyone is
organized and they're drinking their
coffee and they're having their melba
toast and they come to New York and they
go what a nice shot from Connecticut
right I take the one train yes and the
one train is typically good but
sometimes there's weird stuff and I just
want to know how you would handle this
yeah I'm on the train get through two
stops
feeling good right guy walks onto the
train with a juicy yeah peanut butter
and jelly sandwich right you know that
peanut butter and jelly where you've
lathered it on and you put it and it's
like you're biting it's popping out
that's disgusting
so one I don't eat on the train right I
find eating on the train to be
disgusting right this guy though biting
one side dripping out the other all that
Wow
as he's eating it mm-hmm he reaches in
with his other hand to her pocket and
pulls out a bottle of cologne Wow a full
bottle and then go sprint sprint sprint
three around the neck puts it in kind of
like looks around feels real proud of
himself and then bites into the juicy
part of the PB&J what kind of person
every time at a homeless person we were
talking about a guy that had all clothes
he's just gotta rip his clothes he he
was clothed he looked to be sane we did
make eye contact because I couldn't
believe what I was seeing
he looked to be sane in the eyes he
looked like he maybe didn't shower that
morning right
hence the Cologne yeah but I just I
couldn't understand it where did you get
a sandwich from that you also felt the
need why who brings a full bottle of
cologne no I didn't get it smelled
pretty good I can't stand what guys put
on too much cologne it gives me a
headache
do you wear anything no I do not I saw
that zach lavine and the NBA has his own
cologne line right and I was like man I
need to jump all over that get I I don't
I'm not a big cologne guy no I'm not
either I used to be and I don't care
what guys wear it or girls wearing
perfume but when they overdo it
yes it can be one of those things where
I'm like holy crap I just have to get
away with you because your smell is
giving me a headache but who brings the
entire bottle of cologne I don't know
who makes a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich like that you make it nice and
clean so it doesn't fall off the other
side okay I'm an expert in peanut butter
and jelly five a week how does Chris
Simms do peanut butter and jelly in two
I've learned something have you learned
something when you say words right that
have a CN n L you add an H and an R mmm
so if you say I like say that like say
the word clean clean green I've never
heard anyone say like that before clean
but how do you get it diagonal diagonal
cuts either three triangles or four
trying they're silly oh she's my wife
when I go three triangles how do you get
three triangles out of a square right
that's exactly CC so you've got to be
creative you cut one we cut one in half
exactly thank you the syracuse of that
education are you yes peanut burn jelly
on Ezekiel bread you either eat the
crust a sense of left go offense are we
eating healthy I'll be taking care of
the environment
I haven't ranted in a while I've got so
many things I'd like to have had people
message us and say that they've lost a
lot of weight because they went beans
not because one of our amendments for
people that are joining us now good to
hear good to hear but but I would say
now's the time to eat healthy yeah words
of stinky finger gay beach season it's
coming up he's get it ready gay he's
hitting the benchpress and we have our
we have a shirtless photo shoot coming
up do we know thank
5850 who do you got for me
weird peanut-butter-and-jelly human uh i
like raspberry jelly too just so you
know your grape jelly Thank You Brett
sometimes I'll go strawberry yeah you
crunchy or pull or creamy peanut butter
just creamy good cream would you eat
organic peanut butter yeah I can deal
butter that has the oil at the top I
think it does first I don't know because
I make my wife make them for me but
generally don't make your own I don't
make anything we're old school
relationship I go home I make the money
I do those type of things it's maybe an
occasional like heavy lifting job around
the house hey can you move this couch in
here there can I get something off the
top shelf but yet other than that no the
wife has her duties and that's the way
we talk but just dad have a Chris dish
when Chris do you have one thing that no
one else is touching this like for me my
when I grew up my dad was making
pancakes everything else mom was kicking
ass with no the grill occasionally so
she even does the grill oh yeah they
said your wife's cooking it's incredible
it's incredible we send her out on the
grill too well she might count my kids
do like when I make the burgers every
now and then that would be like my hey
make some charcoal black all right you
guys really are the textbook definition
of like the the utilitarian family good
to see your wife Thank You husband my Oh
kids you look grand today thanks Papa
Sims well I can go x-rated too it times
58 Carl banks yes other outside
linebacker opposite of Lawrence Taylor
really a phenomenal football player
von Miller 58 correct um hold on Wilber
Marshall from back in the day yes that
Chicago Washington linebacker babies a
90 still Sims up by his facemask once
what do you mean he big Phil we're gonna
speak Phil you know what that's a good
one to ask him about it was when he was
on the Redskins it was in the Joe
Theismann breakaway tell me this story
and I want to hear a Phil tells it
similar okay actually I don't think I've
ever heard him tell this story perfect
so this'll even be better you get to
hear stories for the first time when he
tells them to me yeah
yes I this usually how I hear most my
did you go to this game no this was the
I was only five this is the Monday night
Joe Theismann break your leg am but this
is full heated Giants Redskins rivalry
at the time and yes
Wilbur Marshall would you Khmer song
it's not the 85 it's 88 sorry I'm wrong
everyone would you compare Wilbur
Marshall to today oh just so that like
people now have an idea cuz I know I'm
never seen him he was like a I'm gonna
say like an Elvis do Merville solar size
great strength go around through his
body around everywhere he left the Bears
of the 85 Bears team he went to the
Redskins after this sax the crap out of
my dad and then yes tries to pick him up
by the face mask which is great and that
is no small quarterback money stretch of
the imagination he's not a small guy now
no so alright so getting back to other
58 I'm gonna miss so many obvious ones
go ahead just start it Matt Milano are
the bills by up Christian Kirksey Thomas
Davis Darren Lee got Jordan Hicks Quan
Alexander those are your linebackers
that actually play linebacker your guy
Carl Lawson one of your one of your
under-the-radar nails he got enough last
year date tone Jones what do you know
Elvis do Merville no boo go booth and
you said Von Miller Mike Stratton
big-time linebacker for the bills in the
60s and then and they had another one of
the 70s Isaiah Robertson both of them
were very highly ranked in Pro Football
Reference Trent Cole
fantastic 58 good ones here Jack Lambert
at the 58 that's in my last call thank
you Peter Boulware rhema luga Antonio
Pierce
Gary Brackett and Jesse Tuggle Wow I
love Jessica that's that to be another
guy like Wilmer Marshall was a lot like
Jesse Tuggle that would be actually very
similar pulling play role player
comparison as well then they all timers
Carl banks Jack Lambert and I can't
believe II didn't get this one Derrick
Thomas gosh damn yeah that hurts anyone
you talk about him all the time I do you
tell the story about him
yeah sax in the game or the game or the
other one where he went through a
period of his career where he was like
all he did was want to rush the passer
and I can remember my dad took me to the
facility is a story I don't know takes
me to the facility of the Giants
facility they're gonna they're gonna
play the Kansas City Chiefs it's not
like a Monday or Tuesday so players
aren't their dad's gonna do something
I'm like wandering the halls I go sit in
a meeting room and one of the coaches I
think it's an offensive line coach just
studying Derrick Thomas watching what he
does right and I'm starting to realize
like damn Derrick Thomas isn't very good
against the run and damn teams are
running right at him and getting 20
yards and I said that I love I've said
the next part out loud I go Derrick
Thomas little overrated huh I'm like
eight what I'm saying this and I can
remember the coach looking at me and
laughing a gun yeah a little bit and
that was when you began scouting for
that Scott I said well there's a nice
touch there though it's great bet we are
we are in a really we're in a funny time
funny time people that have been
listening to us for a long time know
that when you give evaluations it's just
the truth right and none of this is for
impact I think when you started doing
leb Itard people are like oh he's doing
this for impact and then the people that
have come over and started listen to us
they're like no Sims only speaks the
truth right your sand Arnold take from
the last show Monday the show that you
didn't think went well I created a
firestorm of discussion online a number
of comments were I know Sims is only
doing this for attention and I can't
wait until he Sam Darnell starts playing
well and then Sims takes it all back oh
that's fine I mean I could be wrong I
definitely don't do it for attention I
don't even know what everybody says out
there so I would know it not use social
media I mean I wouldn't really know your
salary is not impacted by how many
retweets or favorites or whatever no so
I guess this is just his brain I'm just
I don't even know what I would have said
that was you know all I was trying to
say is that I have concerns about Sam
Donald and that I don't think he is just
a lock down number one pick of the draft
he might go one and I can understand but
I'm just saying for me he's not the kind
of guy I love at the quarterback
position I mean from all accounts it
sounds like he's going one or two he
just not
my favorite one or two quarterbacks that
I've seen in this draft and I just have
a little concerns I'm excited because I
know that right around draft week we are
gonna have Miller up here we'll have
Connor in here and I have some ideas
I've already kind of told you about some
fun stuff to do right and I think you
guys disagree on him and that's healthy
yeah it's the same way in all the NFL
rooms yes what is really interesting
just this is my weekend I'm going to go
back and watch all these guys won again
I am I have to it's just I need to watch
all of them a little bit more
I understand it's so close this year
they all have flaws it's the first year
ever I'm gonna go back and watch the
quarterbacks for a second time and
really give it another thorough deep
dive so speaking of the draft ESPN got
really upset yeah because Fox is
simulcasting the NFL Network right so
now ESPN is gonna put the draft on ESPN
and espn2 and on day three they're
putting it on ABC Wow here's the thing
you don't have to watch any of that jump
because Sims myself and Miller are gonna
be doing the draft live I believe on
Facebook we'll have more details coming
but we're doing all the pics and if you
like the way we break it down we're
doing it even better for the dress and
we'll be faster and we'll be ahead of
the draft that's what you're gonna learn
that's the number one thing everybody
that watched us last year it was like
you guys were like a pic ahead of TV
really yes I just started watching you
guys because yeah yeah where they go to
a commercial the thing that I think that
we do better than a lot of those other
places is that they are you know they
won they have commercials but to also
they start talking about the big stories
like they'll be all pickets talking
about picking one so let me show you
though Tyla it will pick fives awesome
can I know something about the player
what hates wouldn't breathe he's room
LSU let's go back to pick one and show
you our ninth highlight package of the
day yes that's the problem with the NFL
yeah you're right because they go
through periods aware and we only talk
about who is drafting right then that's
it mitt I'm really disappointed that
people think I would just say stuff well
I don't think it's they think that about
you I think that we live in a culture
things right to get attention right and
that's what I think they're thinking
about I am willing right now to say
scout that I might be wrong about saved
Arnold I don't I realize that I realize
it it's that close this year like I said
there's there's issues with everybody
there's greatness with everybody
I mean hey I yeah I came out and I said
Lamar Jackson was the number one
quarterback I still think he has the
highest ceiling am i concerned about
other things going on with Lamar Jackson
to what I say he's my number one
quarterback right now no eyebrows gosh
Allen's jumped him listen this is like
it's a litmus test and yeah okay the
film you see all the great qualities
Lamar Jackson are there's some flaws and
some rawness certainly yes and those are
the things I'm gonna dive into more
again but at the same time it's the
litmus test of also what you do all
around this process and that's where
he's failing right now things that you
have to do with Lamar the number one
comments that I get tweeted at and stuff
for you is you have to watch the bowl
games against the SEC team yeah I get
you LSU and all those I get that you
know but I mean last time I checked
Clemson would whup the [ __ ] out of hell
su and he was pretty good against those
games were so of course ACC was awesome
we can't say that like years past the
ACC is every bit their top quality teams
yeah or every bit as good as the SEC
teams I know they're not Alabama but I'm
just saying they could play with them
yes but I didn't watch Mississippi State
game a moment - oh man Madhu Kyle
Shannon's a favorite coach Richard
Sherman signs with the 49ers yeah and
when talking about Kyle Shanahan he said
this you know we've played him since my
rookie year actually when he was with
Washington he always gives us issues
with plays that we've never seen and
this is the best part the rest of the
league piggy backs on what Kyle has and
they're like oh my God look at these
great offensive coordinators it's like
literally they're just copying what Kyle
did against us for the past five games
so congratulations
you can copycat and then he continues to
say a little bit later Shanahan's
ability to make minor adjustments that
lead to a big impact is quote like he
threw a grenade in a tailpipe it's one
of the best in the sport man he's one of
the best but I would say four years ago
when we first started talking and people
were like oh he's just saying that cuz
he's his friend we're saying that
I mean I don't care if I'm wrong I'm
just I tell you like I just want to
speak it but this is the reason why I
love when guys switch teams right
because then like the truth comes out
like again we I joked about henny going
to Kansas City
the Jaguars just cut Marseille DS Louis
and he's pissed I want to talk to
Marseille Diaz Louis now what is that
locker room like right now right because
that's when it comes out right but -
you're Richard Sherman saying this about
Kyle it's what you said people want to
go play for them because they know what
he can do they it's the reason why Dan
Quinn when he got a head coaching job
said I want couch it exactly right I'll
pay you up make you the highest paid off
that's a coordinator in football you
want this what 20 I already a lot of
this much money I'm gonna pay you more
than you are actually asking for it
really yeah that's gonna help right
right
but yes Kyle to me has a better
understanding of defenses and there are
rules than any of the other coordinators
does that come from his dad or you
always talk about he would sit in with
the types of coordinators gets that more
than anything more than anything so why
isn't that mandatory for offensive
coordinators around the NFL to sit with
defensive coordinators and learn what
other defenses are do they do to a base
level like they will so what's the
baseline but the base level all like
what how you gonna play how does this
coverage play against this formation or
you know just like okay how you gonna
play this play in this cover I put a
bunch out there how do you think they
would line up but that guy understands
is adjustments and things that are gonna
stress the defense out and from that
standpoint where he can find a like I've
always told you a flaw in the rule of
the defense and he'll go okay I see how
they defend trips or to receivers to the
right and two receivers to the left but
I noticed with this one concept it
stresses their rules out of there's
coverage and then he's gonna find ways
to just totally like nily like he would
always focus a little bit on Richard
Sherman when they would play honestly
where because he would have to drop back
in the cover three he would also have to
kind of play the flat and then if you
put someone and he would just put three
guys in one zone he had to come right we
had that was the game
two years ago Atlanta Falcons lost in
the regular season it was a great game
they got job base whatever it may be so
yes there's that and I can still
remember having the conversation with
Kyle after the game I just oh man those
plays you put in we're like such great
Seattle beaters he was like yeah well
you know what they asked Richard Sherman
to do in that coverage is not really
realistic so I took advantage of it
wasn't Richard Sherman small he found a
flaw and what they were asking Richard
they were asking Richard Sherman to do
hey Richard be responsible for the back
third right press bail right like we
always talked about but they were ausco
going greedy and going if you could stop
the slant route to right then that would
be great which isn't so ok he's seen the
slant route five times during the game
already and he hasn't seen anything else
go back behind him let me follow the
slant and all sudden he throws like a
wheel route behind it and a few
questions about that one
well Kyle then go to Robert Soleil be
like I'm seeing things in your defense
and like will he help him out definitely
yes
two other coaches do that they do but I
think that Kyle has the type of
personality and of course has been
granted the type of power and hired the
staff to where you know I'm not trying
to say he's a dictator but he's a
dictator it's all gonna start and stay
with him Kyle has Co complete control I
mean everything yeah I mean it's oh you
want to sign this player you got to ask
Kyle John Lynch you want to sign him
you got a kyle has to sign off but I
would also say it's a little bit Seattle
ish in terms of you allow everyone to
see how that five years ago it's better
to kind of come together and it
definitely is but the Kyle was amazing
at that find it like just take the
Jacksonville game against the 49ers this
year there's Jacksonville the greatest
talented defense we've seen they Jimmy
Garoppolo and his third game ever as a
starting quarterback for the San
Francisco 49ers
he's dicing up the best team and best
events in football like they're not even
there till where Jalen Ramsey and
everybody's coming off the Cylons going
there you remember they were yelling
each other they were fighting because
why because they were going wait my rule
is this and now you're telling me I have
to change it because they've run this
play yeah and that's what will piss a
defense off I always wondered so we
talked about Seattle Richard Sherman and
like the amount of times they would yell
each other and Jacksonville they would
yell each other when you're playing a
Sean Payton a Josh McDaniels a Kyle
Shannon
that knows your defensing and do that is
there any calm though to a defense do
you think where they go men this dudes
really good or I mean they're in the
moment they're freaking the [ __ ] out you
know they're freaking out there but
they're who's freaking out more the
coaches of the play the coaches are
freaking out first cuz they're going oh
crap he's doing things we didn't see on
film and he's found a formation and a
scheme that has stressed our rules out
here and now we're gonna have to go back
to the drawing board here on the fly in
the second quarter and I'm gonna have to
teach my weak side zone dropping safety
but now he has to watch out for this and
I haven't told him anything about this
the whole season but now he has to watch
out for it so that's where it starts
does that just playing an offensive
coordinator that throws off your rules
yeah does that mess you up for multiple
weeks if you're playing then right
offensive coordinators after see but
because we talked about this with
Jacksonville yeah people they saw the
49ers using the full-back bootlegs and
Buffalo yeah okay but Kyle had a variant
rhyme and reason to his bootlegs and
also did other things off that that also
will made the bootleg that much more
stressful so yeah a lot of - like I've
said before a lot of times in the NFL
some of these coaches don't even know
what they don't know and I think that's
one of their bigness weakness is where
the really great coaches know there's
more they don't know and they always
want to learn yeah McVeigh and Shanahan
and Payton and Belichick it's always
learn learn learn I know a lot but I
don't know everything
teach me more I will quit a company if
someone in that company tells me well
this is how we've always done it right I
do not want to work for you you're going
to fail enjoy the rest of the time that
your company is making money but you're
gonna just you're gonna peter out
because that's what happened if New
England doesn't teach people that the
sports world then I don't know who does
I'm watching Bill Belichick at the Epis
Pro Bowl Pro Day workouts down there
with Bradley Chubb teaching him how to
lift and he's like lift your eyes lift
your eyes and I'm gonna won I can't
believe Bill Belichick's even there but
to to see him down there
and he's not doing it for photo ops Bill
Belichick snot trying to get his Q
rating up his knee clout but he's down
there doing it he is
he he's a sick [ __ ] he's gonna draft an
NC State D lineman this wouldn't have a
tell well you stay or they have some
beasts and they got some big guys in the
middle that certainly would be to his
liking all four of those guys actually
are New England type guys I mean
obviously Bradley chubbs not gonna be
there when New England picks unless they
made some crazy trade but you know some
of those other guys they got down there
they're talented that NC State defense
has some big NFL defensive lineman I'm
having a lot of fun watching Patricia
yeah starting to build his defense in
Detroit right so they got Christian
Jones the linebacker who was the other
linebacker they got that had some speed
oh I'll tell you right now I got it
right here but they're also bringing in
Saint Bernard from the Giants right but
they also are just they're bringing in
so many defensive linemen right now and
just like trying him out and he's just
gonna build the Patriots defense in
Detroit no and the fact that he is gonna
have Stafford there too
the Lions are gonna be a blast man I
agree I'm excited to see him become the
head coach
I am I really am yes I did I'm happy for
him just because first of all you know
is what I think of him is just a person
he's a good person that you can trust
that just says it how it is and he has
no ego all the things you would really
admire about a man I'll be shocked if it
doesn't work because he does have a plan
a process it's detailed and it's gonna
be hard to work them we've always joked
about the Patriots South Patriots West
and they never work out but I feel like
right now the Lions and Titans are the
closest we've seen to it really starting
to look good right you have a Patriots
head coach and GM at both spots you have
rabl patrícia Bob Quinn and your guy
John Robinson right they both have good
talent at quarterback I would put
obviously Stafford ahead of Mario yeah
but they're building they're getting
free agents they're getting good guys it
just feels like the first time we've
seen Patriots satellite teams actually
starting to click I I hear you I mean
I'm gonna throw another team I mean
Houston's gonna be in that conversation
too I just mean close they don't have
the GM and that's what the reason
the Rick Smith Bill O'Brien relationship
just does not feel good no it doesn't
now Rick Smith's not there anymore right
because he took the leave of absence
because his wife is sick and he's gonna
help her out for the year thank you yes
but don't worry all good I mean but
still I do think that Rick Smith has
done his best to try to build a Bill
O'Brien type of football team and had
some of those pieces in place already
but man that's another good conversation
I mean there you see South unreal they
were [ __ ] two years ago they were awful
two years ago I mean okay we know the
Colts and what they do in their
rebuilding and I think Frank Reich is
gonna be really good there and I think
their GM Chris Ballard's build it he
knows how to build but then the other
three teams they're like ready now and
these are these are all New England
Belichick Parcells I talked about the
Titans right Jaguars
well that's parcels and parcels and
often writes I mean Coughlin and
Belichick Patriots yeah I would also say
that Kansas City feels more ready to go
than they have in a very long time right
the Chargers getting Pouncy and how we
felt that the Chargers were the one team
other than the Jaguars that could go
into New England and beat the Patriots
the Chargers are ready to rock yes don't
get the first round guard didn't play
last year to lamb Forest lamp right lane
I love lamp right some amen it's your
right I mean the charges we will these
are going to be tough and I don't think
they're fading away right and then I is
the AFC North the weakest division in
the AFC yeah are the bengals the
Steelers the Browns and the Ravens is
that the weakest now or you're gonna to
take the rest of the AFC East
well the AFC is the ad man you know the
West who've man it's really tough I
can't say the North is the weakest
though I especially like people are
sleeping on the bangles still I know the
Bengals they do they were seven and nine
last year I just don't think that's
extremely talented roster it's a lot of
talent in that a green Eifert hires
their collection it's it's gonna be
interesting AMC is coming up because the
NFC was so far superior to the AFC the
last two years it's just comical
especially last year you know what's
pretty awesome yeah this is a
conversation that you can only have when
the Patriots don't
the Super Bowl when the Patriots win the
Super Bowl we look at each other we go
well the favorites probably the Patriots
good luck to everybody else but when
they lose all the guys they've lost it
and the Super Bowl yeah it feels like
it's up for grabs it does you know I
know the entire league I know last year
we're going all the Patriots on the off
season they might go 17 might go
undefeated we're all [ __ ]
well one team that felt that same
pressure was the Seattle Seahawks after
they won in 2013 against the Broncos
people forget as soon as they won that
Super Bowl we looked at the roster he
went this is a dynasty yeah they're
gonna do this for two three years yeah
next season are they gonna go undefeated
all that they go on the run and they
lose on the goal line
to these New England Patriots or it
would have been a dynasty and Michael
Bennett was on those teams yeah and now
he is on the Eagles I was so excited to
watch his press conference when he got
introduced to the team and he did not
disappoint
in addition to saying that dak I'm
coming for you
Eli I'm coming for you Alex Smith you
can't run away from me he also made a
quote that riled people up and he said
in terms of the defensive line I think
it could be one of the greatest he
continued its kind of and this Nona feel
it's all about this part of the quote
it's kind of like Golden State you want
to be able to have those guys that can
come in and shoot and shoot and score
every time I don't understand when
people say a quote that they're supposed
to say that we react in a way in which
it's shocking Michael Bennett how great
do you think that your defensive line
gonna be I think it can be one of the
greatest when you look there's seven
deep with Fletcher Cox and all those
guys like we've already said they're a
great defensive line you're adding him
to me it's only shocking if he goes I
don't think it's good as the defensive
lines I had in Seattle that's shocking
that should be on Good Morning football
and Pro Football Talk him saying it
could be one of the greatest no [ __ ] you
asked that question
to get that response I know I just don't
understand well this is a film franchise
that has really key it's probably doing
to get attention that sees that's the
only reason is it same
yeah it's what we live with it drives me
crazy also it cannot be compared to the
dream team because you need to look at
who is saying what the Eagles won the
Super Bowl this year and added a former
defensive MVP candidate and a guy that's
won a Super Bowl that's a great addition
the old NFL team when they added Nnamdi
Asomugha and Ronnie Brown it was Vince
Young saying it the backup quarterback
is the one that called the team the
dream team that's why that quote was so
ridiculous
Michael Bennett saying they could be one
of the greatest is not ridiculous
because it can be one of the greatest
our second defensive line could be most
people's first defense yeah I just don't
understand why it took legs I don't
understand it either I don't understand
anything really in this world anymore I
can tell you that much that's all
everything's all screwed up what else
does make you think that our environment
but I I have no issue with him saying
that nor do I think that's you know love
like affect know any here they're all
champions it doesn't matter yeah it's
not like it's not like Fletcher Cox can
make huh well he says you think we're
gonna be the grass I'm not gonna work
out today or he's gonna go I am consumed
with pressure right now that Michael
Bennett says we're the greatest the one
thing I want to talk to you about those
he talked so much about you win the
Super Bowl and knowing have to go after
it again and I sat down I went this is
the perfect guy to bring in what I loved
about bringing in Chris long and
LeGarrette Blount last year is these are
guys that waited their entire lives to
taste a Super Bowl trophy and they got
it and to be in that locker room and to
say here's what we did in New England
here's what we did it was great Michael
Bennett coming into that locker room now
and go I know what it's like to have one
and then people putting the target on
your back
it's got to be valuable and I'm curious
you got to the bucks and oh three the
after they won the Super Bowl
did they have anyone in that locker room
that had to defend a Super Bowl
championship do you remember like
anybody what do you mean is there anyone
about oh three team all right that
previously had won a Super Bowl and then
had to defend it was there anyone that
could give what that's like to the team
no I'm thinking off the top of my head I
don't think there's anybody that what do
you think I do I do think it would have
an invaluable now at the time I didn't
realize how relaxed it was until the
next offseason right oh when the
pressure so when the pressure was back
on right where we didn't make the
playoffs and all sudden it was damn what
the hell did we do here
yeah so yes when I first got to the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers everything was you
know roses the other thing was great
we're awesome this defense is wonderful
waters are so pleasant he's good the
offense you know was showing signs of
improvement and it was gonna be Gruden's
second year in the system they were only
gonna get better and they were gonna
assign some players and all of that and
we're gonna repeat right yeah and you
know offseason I didn't know I knew we
had a veteran team so you know we're
practices shorter at times earned hey
we're not gonna meeting say all of that
yes sure but complacency crept crept in
it definitely did we we kind of just I
felt like hey we're the Bucs and we got
these mean bad nasty defensive players
and we're gonna show up and you're gonna
have a hard time scoring points sent us
well that did happen but we had a hard
time scoring to me I ended up losing a
lot of these like close games early in
the year that was the 1310 yeah it was a
lot of those right exactly right but
what I did realize the next year going
into year two there's okay we didn't
make the playoffs Warren Sapp got
shipped out of town he ends up going to
sign with the Oakland Raiders they tried
to get rid of a view of the what they
deemed as the bad apples in the locker
room and I just remember going damn this
off seasons brutal like I mean we were
meeting walkthroughs practice more
meetings every day and that was actually
normal that was normal but things had
become complacent the pressure was off
we won the Super Bowl and I think that's
where like the genius of Belichick you
can never underestimate that and I think
it's one of the things that's been
really impressive about Pete Carroll is
they say what you want and the team
might have some renegades and all that
but man did they show up ready to
compete and play hard every week no
matter what and that really did and
that's what I respect for them for that
so when you look back at that oh three
seasons yeah
you think did you think that teams were
actually playing you guys harder because
you were the Superbowl champions like
when you look at the rest of your career
what without a doubt she because this is
the thing is I go how can you not play
at the same level of intensity every
game but then again you're human it's
not possible how hard were they playing
you uh you're you're the marked man
that's what the opening game open up the
the link in Philadelphia normally if you
guys opened in Philadelphia opened up
because it was a brand-new stadium there
was that rivalry and they beat they
closed down the vet so they wanted to
have them back robber I really did book
in that exactly right so okay here you
are you're the biggest show in the game
hey also we're gonna make you fly to
Tokyo and play an extra preseason game
because you won the Superbowl and you're
a big deal so we went over to Tokyo
I've told you those stories can we tell
one of them sure I think we can tell any
of them you are in Japan in Japan for a
preseason game against the New York Jets
Paul Tagliabue is there all the bigwigs
are there and you have a night off night
on and you are fresh-faced rosy-cheeked
rookie christen but we have to go first
of all to a gathering with the Jets
we're gonna play the Jets they're the
Wayne Chrebet Keyshawn you're gonna give
them Keyshawn on our team right so this
is the business that starts this night
all right this is a story that's always
the goods but I can't give all the goods
because I might compromise some people
but this is where the first story of
that night we're at this little
gathering it's a cocktail era hey you
know welcome jets and Bucs welcome to
Tokyo ba ba ba ba ba okay we do all that
now comes time it's after Keyshawn
starts holding court he of course he was
on the jet so he knows all those players
right but now he's on the Bucs
he's holding court and he's telling
everybody that he's the best receiver in
football that's that's what Keyshawn
does I'm the best receiver of both I'm
better than Terrell Owens that's he's
got people around him and he is telling
everybody that he is better than Terrell
Owens Richmond Kay who was our GM for
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers at the time
walks Baez he's telling this story and
Keyshawn who and course rich is indebted
the key shot cuz he traded to get
Keyshawn and then paid him all this
money at the time so and then they want
a Super Bowl right and so this is Keith
this is Richmond Kay's guy Keyshawn I
mean so he got rich rich rich rich
come here all right rich tell these guys
who's better quiche me RTO and Rich
McKay sits to ever second he looks out
of that I swear he looked at I'm like
man you're really gonna make me answer
this question in front of everybody and
he goes hey Keyshawn you're a hell of a
player when you when you catch the ball
it's first down he goes but man when tio
catches the ball it's touchdown and what
happened every play the 20 people that
were listening just erupted and you know
Keyshawn what was he doing he can handle
it okay
got thick skin okay Keyshawn is great he
wasn't like rich really he laughed and
he was like a good your ass out of here
anyway but he was great like that that
was also the same trip where I went on a
shopping spree with Keyshawn that song
by like $40,000 in luggage
yeah that was amazing - yeah you've
never told me that I know I never told
you that kind of luggage I expensive 140
Luiz store yes let's do a Luiz store and
he I mean at least Keyshawn had cash
okay he was number one pick of the draft
and then got a renegotiation with the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers you spend like a
good amount of time with Keyshawn and
all yeah Keyshawn I had a good
relationship I know you think I think
you think it's not good cuz of the whole
like your balls funny in cash you know
me and Keyshawn had a very good
relationship we had a lot of good laughs
yes I respect Keyshawn I do I've
interviewed him for that company thews
EO and I found him to be a good guy he's
a good guy and as tough as hell and
takes no crap from anybody so yeah he
might have been as talented as his
number one pick in the draft but when I
talk about tough football players and
fearless yeah I'm ready to compete
Keyshawn is one of the top of my mind
Keyshawn will fight you and he got in a
fight in the back of a plane which we've
money we've talked about that man what I
love though about that is that is what
can happen after you in Super Bowl yeah
I'm not going to curfew I'm doing
whatever I want and here's Gruden going
I'm the reason you guys want a Super
Bowl and that he has no control or that
the NFL sends us to Tokyo in general
because you've won the Super Bowl and
you have no control or the fact that we
go there and when I tell you our clock
human clock was messed up for the next
week I truly will look back at that
always and go that was the start of
messing
sup Wow I mean because you would walk
out of the hotel room and it would be
2:00 in the morning and Brad Johnson
would be sitting on the hallway floor
reading the newspaper at 2:00 in the
morning because nobody could sleep it's
a 12 hour time difference we were in
training camp full schedule every day
we're flying to Tokyo and get ready for
this schedule it really messed our team
up damn sorry are you gonna call my dad
yeah let's call your dad come ready girl
we have a few things to talk with big
Phil one we're gonna ask about Wilbur
Marshall pickin up by his face - he lied
to us the last time he talked he lied
he's gonna answer a liar and apparently
he's going on other radio shows and
telling them things and that's we're not
going to stay hello hello
always expect at least somebody to come
on hey you ready to go on bleacher
report with Dumb and Dumber no I'll
never get that so y'all kissed me when
you just y'all answer make fun of me so
it's snowing here y'all doing it early
today because you know you're all going
get going at home make sure you have
your umbrella would you leave today Adam
you know because I don't want that style
of yours thank you I appreciate ya so
the reason we're calling you early and
the reason that there's never anyone the
buffer is because of what happened two
weeks ago we're still a little hurt big
Phil you lied to yourself you know you
lied to Christopher and it was
embarrassing for both of us that you
told him that you were sick but instead
you were at Parise he's getting a lift
during a snowstorm and I just want to
know
we helped like I don't think you don't
understand that I don't think people
will be talking about Phil Simms if you
weren't doing quarterback will in his
life you know tell your mom you know
that's what I was doing actually oh you
were telling somebody he was yes I would
throw what
young man one night young but so there
you go so both of you can you know guess
my took it kind of like everything else
it's like being married you know
everybody takes me for granted you guys
were taking me for granted so I kind of
you know lets you know that it's you
know step on you a little bit yeah you
stepped on us I don't know if I can
believe that story because you know
you're a freaking liar now just like you
being Mary Adams dating we when you you
you become a professional liar and I'm
really good at it well I have another
bone to pick with you
here I was here I was thinking that we
were the spot where Phil Simms came on
to drop hot takes and I hear you're all
with Adam shy saying that if it was me
without question my number one pick for
the Browns would be Josh Allen and
you're given headlines to other people
Phil and I can't take it anymore
really that that was out there I didn't
even know oh that was out there yeah you
don't want people to steal your takes
but you're out here givin in your takes
to people I like how he is expected he
expects he should know even though he
hasn't been on the computer it's in
since he said it look in social media or
the crap but that's another thing so you
know I said that and and as I do and I
say though you guys right now I reserve
judgment till the last moment that
determined my order of guys right
because you mean you're not an idiot
like me and just come out and say it
after you watch them all and just go
with it right away
well I usually do that you know
backtrack and you've heard me Kris for
the last couple days like wow yeah it's
close it's a weird year it's confusing
you know and the big thing is it's
always you know I Bill Cowher we were
talking for a few minutes I said this to
you son is an atom and telling you that
we were talking about it we go what's
more important a talented the
quarterback that's going to be drafted
or who the coordinator is right
yeah and I just went it's the ding it's
the coordinator no it's it's you're
right it isn't in a lot of cases it's
the overlook thing from what we say I
mean you know just like a perfect
example I think is Jared golf you know
Jared Goff yeah it was a great year
right but he got a new coordinator in
there he throws 28 touchdowns seven
interceptions and this is not a comet to
put down Jared golf but I think there's
other 20 other quarterbacks we could
take in the other foul and I go they
would have done 28 touchdowns and seven
interceptions it's hard to separate the
two
right so it's pill and just get so good
on you know talent around him all those
things we saw that with Case Keenum with
the perfect offense the talent of a team
we saw with him and you know Nick Foles
you know we've never talked about him in
his whole career he went 21 27 28 and 2
well that was kind of pushed aside like
it was an accident nobody talked about
it but here he goes
they cater the offense to him good
football team and now you know what was
it you need to number one to two number
twos to go Kenny alright right what do
you but Phil what do you think you know
for certain about these quarterbacks in
the draft if we don't know the order and
there's a lot of things up in the air
what do you know for sure about these
why do I know for certain okay the Josh
Allen even if he fails it will still be
good enough to be a middle-of-the-road
starting quarterback and he will be in
other words if he fails because you know
I said to Christopher I he was to 33 or
237 at the combine yeah okay let's lose
10 pounds even though he's in good shape
but it's just it's too much weight and
he does rely on his arm his arm is great
we know that mobility size and arm
that's all I know for sure about him
Josh Rosen I know he is right he plays
quarterback in college exactly like a
pro would in just a pro offense yep it
really feels the pocket well can look
people off throws a beautiful spiral
makes it look easy
you know never panic so that that you
know mmm right what do you worry about
that's another thing Lamar Jackson what
do I know
big play waiting to happen every time he
touches the ball he's dynamic he looked
awful throwing the football to combine
but I didn't get that sense watching the
tapes it does worry me a little bit but
you know so we're gonna lose a little
bit in the throwing but we gain it and
the other part which is going to be
accelerated or really accentuated I
guess you should say once it goes to the
pros which we saw with deshaun Watson
right and Who am I missing Baker
Mayfield I think I got a great feel for
him
yep just can play good thrower the
football competitive energetic all those
things we know that and who died miss
Darnell Arnold well Sam darn 'old I do
like the as quick feet
yeah the motion doesn't bother me he
doesn't break you know would be
quarterback here it's a windy motion but
he doesn't break the angle of his arm
for people that are out there are most
important so he can get it out of his
hand quick and how do I know that
because they throw on ton of screens and
a ton of hitches and stuff like that
right where it's you know fake it he's
all off-balance and he just swings it
out there he does that well so and he's
got good at FL sighs and you know does
he have a great arm that here's an
average NFL arm I would say you know in
the middle of the pack if you want to be
right item that way right so it's
interesting because they all have great
they all have things that you watch and
go oh that's impressive but they all
have flaws too so yeah it's again it's
the first year ever I'm gonna go back
and watch him again - I mean because
dad's been watching him and he poses
questions to me - and I go you know yeah
you're right I haven't thought about
that whatever so yeah I mean certainly
our dad I want a real quick conversation
here which I think we had this dad and I
had this conversation the other night on
the phone but I think it's worthy of
calling in here well the Jets the Jets
trading to number three and the pick to
number three right you know there's a
lot of talk out there well they just
moved up there and they're probably
still formulating their plan and dad I
think to me when when we talked about it
he laid it out I think exact
the way at least I would want Agnon was
thinking the cagnes thinking what
they're thinking there and dad I just
think you should share it with share
with us your big [ __ ] I don't think I
don't think you move up there Adam and
Chris I don't think you move up and go
well we're moving up there because we
know somebody's gonna come one of the
three guys we like and I just I can't
imagine that you move up because you
know the guy that you want will be there
at 3:00 right and and of course you
can't the two that I think you have to
take off I'm just going by is Josh Allen
and Arnold right and Arnold you have to
take them off so it leaves me to Baker
Mayfield and I just go does that fit
what the Jets are gonna do you know I
don't know Jeremy Bates I can't remember
all this I know who he's been with in
his career one of the Jets one on
offense Mike the kangmin likes big
quarterbacks this you know ran that Jay
Cutler offense in Denver remember like
in Jay Cutler's like you know boots
aggressive play action passes down the
field kind of stuff and that sounds like
bait for me right but but you know I
would put this into a - yeah I was my
second thought and it would be really
close to that would be Josh Rosen right
just because he is NFL ready right I
mean it is he's ready he looked a little
more athletic at the combat and I
expected the body wasn't you know and
he's you know he's not Ben
Roethlisberger he's got the sturdiest
looking thing I've ever seen back there
right but he knows he really really
knows he knows how to play the position
better than any other quarterback in the
draft if that's a way to put it yeah
that's awesome that would be that would
be the - it's gotta be one of those two
guys I would think I would think so I'm
with you on the Mayfield thing I mean I
think that's that that was when dad said
it and I was like yeah you're you're
right it's because you can't you can't
go to number three and think oh well
maybe darned old or Allen will be later
I think the way things look right now
you got to think there seemed to be the
hot commodities these rumors aren't just
coming out of nowhere so even though
you're not hearing it anywhere well
I haven't heard any of my coach friends
just go Sam Darnell's the best
quarterback in the draft he's the number
hands-down yeah Phil is anyone saying
that to you I have not had one person
say it to me I don't then why is this
happening Phil well it's still early -
yeah it's early Adam and but meaning
they know so much about these guys
already they've got you so much homework
on the quarterbacks because there are
all these teams that want them and
everything but I did talk to one guy and
just by accident it was in the NFL and I
really trust his opinion and he had
Arnold as the fifth quarterback right
and I just went Wow he goes nope he goes
I want the other I would take the other
four over that's where your son has them
yeah I mean I made him for I made a
frozen five remember yeah but I think
you well I mean when I originally came
out with it I put it in one but I can't
now he hasn't had one right now I mean
it's like you and I talked about it's
like the litmus test he's yeah the film
it's great is there some raw areas as
crazy plays he's so athletic all that
but all the other things you know the
combine throwing no hiring of an agent
you know didn't look like there was any
really mechanic work at his throwing of
the combine well he's working with his
he's working with his one of his best
friends right who's a trainer so all
those things are he's failing in that
area and I think that's concerning to me
too but it's like but but why but when
he goes to an organization that won't
they fix that yes go ahead I'm sorry
about that the football would be like a
professional golfer standing up there to
hit the ball and he doesn't turns he
just takes his arms and swings and hits
them just with his arm don't turn you
know how a golfer turns way back to hit
yeah you know bad Lamar Jackson just
stands there flat-footed nothing moves
but his hands at his arm and he hits it
he just makes it happen he just tries to
do like sudhi you guys look at that and
go wow if he gets his bottom half and
this is amazing or do you go wow oh that
the torque he just lets his arm be an
independent contractor slingshot like do
you but I'm saying is do you look at
that and go wow if we get his torso
involved this will be great
or do you go it's really hard to
radically change a motion you gotta be
who they are you can't change them
really change an offensive lineman you
can't you know I had this argument a
price that this story to you I'll tell
you anyway here
Bill Parcells said all Simms you and
this about the quarterbacks I said yeah
bill
you tell your nose tackle 9,000
different techniques but don't tell the
quarterback anything that makes a lot of
sense the most important guy your team
looked at me and he goes that's a good
point
[Laughter]
we've seen enough on film at least I
know and you have to we've seen enough
on film to go wow when he gets in the
right position you he makes the rose or
you go that's special he did some
opening days I just watched him again
last night
he made some throws I went wow can he
look at these and go that felt great I
need to do what I did there and I don't
think they do that enough but he made
some throws and did exactly what you'd
like to see how a pro quarterback to get
position and move and throw the ball and
you can see the ball spinning so hard on
the tape and of course it's right on
target too but the problem is you don't
see enough of them and seeing all this I
think he probably will be the fifth
quarterback taken if I had to guess but
I do I do believe he'll go in the first
round because it now I can't wait and I
will try to find out somebody who works
him out and just to hear what they say
and but the see what he looks like in
person watching him throw yes I talk to
people at Louisville University of
Louisville my Center in Morehead state's
always around there he says when he
watches in practice practice he throws
it great and the guy kind of knows what
he's talking about Carl Schmidt so he's
good pregnant I know Carl sure - oh you
know
yeah doesn't he work the the Paul
Hornung award yeah that's right yeah
well I mean come on I was a big deal
down there in Louisville Carl Schmitt
knows me not the other way around
Louisville big Phil one last one today
was episode 158 and so a 58 that we were
talking about was Wilbur Marshall I
brought up Wilbur Marshall and I brought
up how he tried to pick you up by your
face mask and I think it was the 1988
Monday Night Football game right after
he sacked you yeah so what happened what
did your dad say I was like actually I
don't think I've ever even talked to my
dad sighs don't know what happens I'll
say this this is my recollection I'm
pretty sure he sacked dad he literally
tried to pick that up by his facemask
now dad's a big [ __ ] hence the name
big and and I believe dad threw the ball
at him all right big Phil what happened
from your point of view I can't quite
remember my recollection is not that
great but I think I did we got it I
grabbed his facemask and his helmet came
off by accident and it did I didn't jerk
his helmet off I just grabbed it we were
kind of tussling and his helmet came off
and we'll the marshal look I wouldn't
want to meet him anywhere but on the
football field where I get everybody
around me he was fast he can talk the
game he was one of the best talkers who
that I ever played against real Haley
him and Richard it but just mumble a few
words but I got the message but those
are the best guys and we'll the marshal
was such a great player oh my gosh yeah
in his prime he was truly and that bear
defense and all that he was literally
unblockable what constitutes a good
trash talker for Phil Simms like what is
a Wilber Marshall thing he could have
said they'd be like oh he's good at that
well I that are good trash talkers are
guys that you know that they might fight
you even there on the football field so
that worries you you don't want that to
happen because you know you're gonna
lose and they just say things to you and
you go oh my god he really meant that
and it's Charles Haley I can't give you
the whole spectrum even on
your podcast yeah I know it right back
to back times ball flies up and I he's
walking behind me and I am NOT going to
turn and say anything to him or look at
him and he gets in my ear and he goes
I'm gonna kill you buddy
said it but he said it with some other
tones and things some other four-letter
words and things right it was racial it
was yes and it was to the point and I
remember me just going oh my god he
really means that he will kill me and
it's so funny all those things happen
and then when I see Charles Haley
nowadays or wherever you know we laugh
and it's great awesome
you know but Charles Haley was the
number one for sure
Wilbur would be right there and then
Richard get the quiet talker who just
was great and you knew it - yeah thanks
Phil you're the man dude done with you
we have no more use for you yeah that
was good no the Wilbur marshal Charles
Haley I'm gonna kill you it kind of
softened me up a little bit and the
truth is I just missed your voice I just
needed it in my ears all right dad what
that will get you in here soon
oh sure I keep hearing that you know
when I show up I get a question this one
is from reddit you know how much I love
reddit and this is from Chelsea Saints
if you had $100 to bet on a player
making the Hall of Fame who is currently
25 years or younger who would you bet
your money on I have written down the
seven names that I saw most repetitive
eated in that post Odell Bosa Ramsey
Carson Wentz DeAndre Hopkins Keyon
O'Neal and Zeke how old's Aaron Donald
o-type an Aaron Donald age and it should
pop up he's 26 he doesn't fit designate
the kind of it damn it well I mean if I
have bet money on all those
I feel like there's somebody else were
missing too I'm sure like the guys that
just came out in the draft but it's like
you don't know if Dashon Watson can do
that his entire crew no no no no you're
right it's got to be something they're
not gonna bet on the Holmes who has even
played right right I'm just trying to
think is there anybody that's been semi
proven to this point to where we could
say that about so like Khalil Mack is
heat 26 - I just but you would have
taken Khalil Mackel for Odell and Ramsey
and all those guys well I just feel like
at those positions and where they are at
at their career like I know enough that
they are on a Hall of Fame track right
now like obj when you first said it he
was my pick number one but you know also
I mean like videos and France and [ __ ]
like that bother me - that's that that
will hurt your chances does Odell
Odell's pace right now is absurd Ramsey
give me the other names bozo DeAndre
Hopkins peon O'Neal Zeke yeah I would go
with Odell Beckham jr.
I mean Odell Beckham jr. through the
first few years of his career is on a
pace that nobody enjoys no nobody's been
him missing that year that's gonna hurt
him this year that he missed that right
but I mean you have more faith in Ramsey
or Bosa oof Jalen Ramsey or Bosa super
young super awesome both of them - I
guess I don't know they're there I guess
I have a hair more faith in Ramsey mmm
but it's not by much it's not because
all those worries me about those guys at
that position - he's long he's a bigger
corner you know sometimes when those
guys lose their quickness and their
ability to be serious about Richard
Sherman you can lose it Richard Sherman
gonna be a hall-of-famer yeah yes a lot
of people got upset when you called sue
a first-ballot hall-of-famer the other
day really a lot of we were like sue
first-ballot hall-of-famer that's crazy
yeah I'm sorry everybody I really do
think he is I mean he is a guy that
there has not been a lot of people in
the history of this fort that are built
and play like him yeah but its
production - it is pronunce had good
production phenomenal production all
right let's get into some of your scouts
and I want to we've already done running
back Steve Jets c'est quoi
the guys we've done quarterbacks and
you've you're gonna dive back into them
again
so we are going to talk about the
quarterbacks on Monday as well but I'd
like to get two wide receivers you've
watched about eight of them who are the
eight names that you've watched okay
I've watched Calvin rigidly Calvin
Ridley DJ more Christian Kirk
Courtland Sutton DJ shark which really
messed me up because I was looking for a
DJ Clark when I was trying to look over
the stats and I was like damn there's no
DJ Clark and then I realized it's chart
you got James Washington cut and I still
have the kid from Washington what is it
Pettis or something like that that I
still on my dock here that I haven't got
to yet now so what's actually funny as I
thought about this you are kind of like
a GM people like that go out there
whether it's the guys that stick to
football Conor or Matt they watch all
year round but as you said before the
GM's kind of get brought in at this
point and the lists have been cut down
by the scouts and that list is presented
to the to the GM and the head people and
then they start getting involved yeah
and that's sort of where you are at well
to a degree yeah I would be like
obviously I wouldn't say the GM it would
seem more like I'm the pro personnel guy
you're the Commission's gonna know the
college guys he's got around and
visiting them during the season
so he's gonna have a pretty good feel
but you're Pro personnel you've been
looking at the 53-man roster and now
you're like what am I looking to fill in
for gotcha
right so is you you said there's a top
four yeah okay so if we just had to say
top four right away and and I gotta
watch the kid from from Clemson the Deon
Cain case yes but I don't think he is in
the class of these other guys just from
my TV scouting but the top four Calvin
Ridley DJ charkh DJ more hmm and
Courtland son all right
you are the pro player personnel of a
team you are at 15 and you have one wide
receiver who is your number one wide
receiver in this year's tour
I think the number one receiver is the
obvious answer I think it's Calvin
Ridley interesting now what's
interesting about this and again it's
it's funny it's like the theme of the
year it's like there's just not slam
dunks there's always some piece of
evidence missing where you just go man I
wish they saw this a little bit more I
wish I had this how hard is it to watch
Calvin Ridley's film it's hard I mean
it's more hard to watch jaylen Hurst
play quarterback yes I came downstairs
and you said you said after like the
second play you were like I can't
believe they won with this it's just
amazing I mean I've never I wrote in my
notes at one time I don't think I've
ever seen a guy opens so much in my life
who never got the ball because of course
you know jaylen Hurst he looked and if
he didn't wasn't wide open he wanted to
tuck it and run the football that's what
I did but so how do you evaluate a guy
who's playing with a quarterback that
will never play that's where like the
personal workouts are gonna really come
in handy this year more than ever I
think even with like gonna think back to
the quarterback conversation when my dad
said like yeah there's some great
strengths but they all have little
weaknesses here or there so Ridley it's
the guy that I just looked at right away
and go he's the most Pro ready okay
his physical skills aren't real they
really are I think I wrote down my pro
player comparison than him I wrote he is
here I'll just tell you read like I said
kid is really safe pick does everything
well with no weak weakness he is a less
explosive Amari Cooper coming out or a
stronger better route running Marvin
Jones coming out that was kind of my
comparison there that type of guy cuz
the thing is with Amari we got to see a
Maury go up and compete for balls right
you got to see him outrun people and see
that burst on the 50-yard throw how do
you how do you watch film of a guy where
you don't really get anything I know you
have to piece it together it's a pain
like you told me that you were watching
him make cuts and be wide open and then
be like okay so I can study his cut his
route running right but then there's
limited evidence of exposure after the
catch right yeah you're piecing together
a handful of place over two years and
you're just going okay Wow
well it's the SEC and man he made the
LSU safety miss and then turned it up
that outran the corner for another 30
yards is there any that was to me when I
look back at that really stacked Draft
with Odell I think there was a 14 right
Ebron yeah we didn't really seal out of
Iran but he had a few plays where he
really [ __ ] some people up and like
just like Miami was the play on the 80
yard and and because there was a lot of
examples we had to extrapolate those
plays to more that's my only concern I
hear that but the but he's also Alabama
probably top recruited kid top recruit
the thing that tells me that he's he's
all over the details is even with the
quarterback play never takes a playoff
runs hat routes good run blocker I mean
yes does everything he's in Alabama he'd
have to do those things yes the other
thing too is he has a real understanding
of rail running not only just a physical
ability to run the route which I take
into account like can a guy just stick
his foot in the ground and make an out
cut on the out route seamlessly and not
lose speed can do all of those but he
also understands how to set defenders up
or understanding the play and how it
coincides with the coverages he's being
played in to to go oh okay there's a
hole right here in this zone defense let
me push this dropping zone linebacker in
a little bit more to widen that hole so
then when I break out and sit down in
the hole it's even that much easier for
the quarterback to throw and I was
watching the combine and Steve Smith was
watching him every time he put his foot
in the ground Steve Smith was like wow
that is just incredible that's what he's
really good at now he's a high effort
and runner like that would be to my one
things I would say like he really you
have you can tell he's digging in to run
right where you know guys like Odell
Beckham jr. and he was coming out I was
just going down I mean he looks like
he's jogging and he's running for for
sure this is the pro ready kind of
underneath guy you know he can do it all
okay he's gonna have he has enough speed
and size that he can do it all he really
can now do I think you know again like
acceleration after the catch where he's
just gonna pull away from people and
make 70 yard touchdown runs I don't
think so acceleration of the catch where
you make make it catching them run for
another 20 or 30 yards yeah I see it
more like that who's your number two
okay this I mean I'm filling this out on
this I'm going on the
why I'm having a conversation here
that's what this is for I know
so I am joining this adjust is as I'm
sitting here I don't all right my number
two of course that's between deejay more
the Sutton kid or the DJ karke charkh
kid yeah I know
it's really hard how about this you want
to talk why don't you give us your
scouting reports give your comparisons
give your final whatever and we'll work
it out here on live on yeah I think I
have to say my number two gosh yeah this
is again it goes back to the quarterback
conversation there's gonna be a little
more than years pass and I know people
out there gonna go while he's making
excuses I promise you I'm not
I am the mister I will put myself out
there and let everybody [ __ ] on me all
the time that's what I do
and I mean that should be my nickname
Chris I'll let you [ __ ] on me Sims I
don't you don't think it's good but
either way I think DJ Moore would be my
angel more yes DJ more from Maryland
right breakdown give me a finger go my
number two okay but don't this is the
qualifying statement I wanted to make
that is going to be a little bit
dependent this year on going what do I
have on my team at receiver already and
where do I think this guy can fit in
this type of offense so I'm more than
airing any of these guys being team
changing receivers I think they are not
capabilities but I can't put the stamp
of approval on them like we could with a
holy Oh Jones coming out or of course
you know or even the year where it was
Odell Mike Evans and Brandon cooks like
we knew all of them are gonna be good I
could put a long-ago she's just really a
matter of how do I rank them I was
thinking that this DJ more kid is the
Kevin white - Calvin Ridley's Amari
Cooper um like the athletic like busted
out for a 70 yard touchdown guy yeah
well okay so this is the thing
he is extremely talented in fact he's
the guy that I think excites me the most
him and DJ charkh excite me the most
okay DJ more I I mean just he has a
running backs body he's six foot he's
210 pounds
he's very special that way he
can he has an extra gear he has great
balance on contact he can run away from
anybody he can make people miss in space
the problem is Maryland's quarterback
wasn't very good and here and go routes
and stay routes I mean that's that's it
that's all he ran when I say a state
route I meant it was like it's a screen
where he just turns and looked at the
quarterback and if there's too many
people in the box to stop in the run the
quarterback throws it out to him and
goes hey DJ more make something happen
but I wrote alright I could've should I
just start reading it a little bit I
want to hear your final your overall all
right all right so so the other thing I
wrote at the thing I go he's the reverse
Sean Davis remember Sean Davis came from
Maryland yes what was it talking about
Shonda oil just beat deep and does these
things and it's so raw don't evaluate
the stats and everything else or or you
he might be raw but you got to evaluate
the player and then physical and what I
always saw in Sean Davis and I remember
I got in an argument with this a Miller
is I just said I don't know I know he
got beat on deep routes because he was
like his technique was so horrible and
he was backpedaling and like running in
a 360 degree angle it means all over the
place but yet there was enough clips for
me to go oh he's the fastest guy in the
field
oh he throws his body around and then
poaching and they could fix it so that
was coaching issues that's why I kind of
look at DJ Mort but I wrote basically
this at the end of the day the kid has
superstar traits he's not polished he's
not day one ready like a Ridley but he's
a better Ross specimen great strength
balance acceleration quicks they're all
off the charts route running needs to
work needs work but I'm not worried I
mean 80 yards screens taking it to the
house are harder than learning how to
run around so that's what I took away
from it more than anything but what's
really funny too is the more and more we
do the draft the more and more we learn
about these coaches in college we would
always laugh about what's going on at
LSU and the roster for Maryland to have
all these athletes right that just don't
seem to be coached that great right I
mean exactly right that's what you have
to take into account akin to account
what he's being asked to do is it
realistic who's asking and who's asking
him to do he tore up the combine
he's a freak of nature I mean he's a
Steve Smith type of player that I think
actually is more explosive than a Steve
Smith
I wrote to me the component of all calm
is Stefon Diggs she's so much more of an
explosive stronger man than Stefon Diggs
every night yes yes I mean we've seen
Stefon Diggs in person yeah this guy is
not built like this kid this kid yeah
this guy's got like 20 pounds exactly
right this kid is legit I mean this kid
will run through arm tackles like I'm
running back I'm gonna just read you
some of the notes I wrote like you know
body control as good as it gets I mean
when they throw him back shoulders and
things like that it's effortless I mean
it doesn't matter how ball how bad the
ball is you know he's just 20 pounds on
stuff on day right his acceleration
makes him a double move King because he
can start and stop and I could be up to
full speed within three steps so I wrote
his stop restart ability is amazing it's
off the charts good I mean route tree
not extensive slants goes and screens
definitely a little raw in that
department but because of the speed and
quicks he was still able to separate and
get room and he has more room to grow
very good at the line of scrimmage
always gives themselves a two-way go off
the ball amazed with his strength I
really like this kid plays the position
with a physical presence he reminded me
of juju Smith Susur except he's way more
explosive and do more after the catch
this kid can be a superstar to me he
could be so he has a higher ceiling than
Calvin riddle I believe so this kid has
a Odell Beckham ish type of high ceiling
but you don't get to see all the
evidence always like you did with the
Odell Beckham down here right all right
yeah I'm pretty I was I'm surprised kid
I like this kid a lot all right
just not a safe bet I'm trying to act
like a real GM Pro personnel good for
you okay thanks yeah cuz I would say in
the past you look I like speed I know
sometimes I just go with what I like
it's probably why I'm you know I came
out with so hard with Lamar Jackson is
the guy I watched on film and I just
said man there's more amazing than
anybody else I get it right all right so
then who do you have it three is it
shark or is who was the other one
it's Courtland Sutton Sutton or charkh
that's your final four yeah so Kirk Kirk
C doesn't leave those Christian Kirk
doesn't like he's not in their class
he's destruction Cristian Cristian Kirk
is a total slot receiver that's what he
will be throughout his career I really
think he's more of a I think I wrote is
there any chance for a jest a slot
receiver to be so good at the slot that
he can actually pass up somebody who can
be more multiple yes
there is definitely that more times than
not know but like let's say like a
sterling Shepherd I mean I think that's
what he was drafted out as a job at the
Giants I can't remember who was drafted
after him but they drafted him basically
to go like no we're good on the outside
now we're gonna let you work the slot
because people are gonna try to double I
don't for you when you're doing your
ranking can someone be so good at the
slot definitely yes it for me yes that
can happen I mean DJ Moore's in the slot
a whole lot but yes certainly if you
blow me away yeah the problem is a lot
of times in college they don't have
enough good offenses to really have a
true slot yeah they're not doing easy to
get there is more all right so you're
getting Sutton or charkh at number three
he gets so stressed out about getting
this right I do it's like really hard it
really is hard I guess I'm gonna go with
Sutton okay
it's tough how about this we're not
officially ranked yeah I want to listen
to you on both start with Sutton what's
your overall okay I'm just gonna start
reading cuz I can't remember all the
[ __ ] okay
all right I mean the Sutton six threes
218 pounds
he ran a what a four or five for
something along those lines he around a
four five to four or five four oh I'm
looking at Cameron Sutton the cornerback
that got drafted by tennis right this is
Cortland Sutton for SMU okay but I just
wrote this just started but obviously
he's a big kid you know where he is out
on the field that's easy only seen a few
catches so far but man I like what I see
in this kid he can make people miss in
space which is very rare for big guys
okay change the direction for the size
is very good and then I wrote in
parentheses six five seven three cone
that's phenomenal size and it was one of
the best I think in their book are
certainly up there okay alright it was
actually second behind only two other
guys which is amazing for a guy that's
220 pounds at that side
and I wrote this has been a complaint of
mine in the past with guys like Kelvin
Benjamin and Josh Dotson big receivers
who couldn't really do anything after
the catch it was always jump ball or
catch it and fall down this guy showed a
little bit more than that strength shows
in all areas of the game not that my
mind is alone but I am impressed with
the ability to accelerate and get to top
speed for a big guy route running is
still up for debate this was early on
still but I wrote go slants screens
corners not real sharp or precise with
any of his route running cuts off the
wrong foot a few times but looks like
more like he hadn't been coached more
than anything to me breaks down almost
always a little choppy at the atop of
his brakes wish he would come off the
ball with a little more aggressive at
times and which they but also threw
throw the ball deep to him or he had
horrible quarterback play again another
issue evaluating this year when he
thinks he might get the ball he gets
when he when he thinks he might get it
he gets off the line of scrimmage with
aggression and and you could see it
hands are solid a few tough catches that
I would like to have seen seen him catch
but I'm not concerned his catch radius
is ridiculous and his size really makes
him an easy target for a quarterback I
mean he was unbelievable again and
adjusting the ball for a big guy it was
nothing for him to catch a back shoulder
that was outside of his catch radius
still catch it dragged feet and bounced
things like that I thought were off the
charts
I wrote SMU cute quarterback not good
ball everything remind you of anybody
yeah hold on let me see who I wrote down
big strong kid who DB's will have to
think twice about jamming at the line of
scrimmage because he will throw them
around he's got very good acceleration
impression impression for I'm impressed
with the size and his ability with yak
after the catch which you don't see for
this size often saw enough 50/50 ball to
know he can go get it raw as a route
runner but I like him more than a Josh
Dotson coming out he's very similar to
an al Sean Jeffrey I wrote somewhere
between 33 and 50 which I haven't done
the rest of the draft yet he meant maybe
it was a late first rounder
I didn't think Josh Johnson was worthy
of the pick that the Redskins picked him
at right
and when we saw what Josh Jackson was
capable of last year in little breasts
like he's a jump ball go deep King he
can do it know about it to count the
comparison from Land's early on nfl.com
was mu seen Mohamed oh I get that I
didn't think that that far back in the I
think he's a bigger man than motion
Mohamed though he's he's gonna play a
lot bigger than motion all right that
means DJ shark this is the speedster
from LSU that around a four three four
at the combine with a 40 inch vertical
and we know that the quarterbacks at LSU
are really never enough no and the
quarterback wasn't bad this year I'll
say that so wasn't his fault their
offense can be an issue at two they're
just it's an old-school offense it's
like let it pull the guard downhill and
you know maybe if we get one on one
we'll throw it every now and then
yeah 6-3 199 like you said first of all
again
another guy maybe he's got superstar
talent I mean he really does tall I
thought he was gonna be smaller than six
$31.99 everyone pitched him to us like
he's gonna be like a scatterbug like 510
175 and he's 6-3 200 he is uh he's good
man I don't even know where I got them
ranked yeah okay I got it like digest
but here we go let's just hear it I
think reading him now I think I might
have him ranked higher than Sutton okay
tall thin long wide receiver like not
thin wear but he's not too thin though I
wrote looks good in his uniform like
wiry muscle like an a jade green type in
his uniform not like frail where you're
like if they hit him he might break
right
he I wrote he can fly and I underlined
it four times gets on Safety's toes
before they can even turn and run I mean
holy [ __ ] he can OBG run I mean I just
saw a hit route where he turned it up
verse auburn and ran up the Cylons and I
wrote Wow
and I underlined it three more times
watch out for those OB G's guys oh but
alright don't get to see route that
route variety but looks like he can
really stick his foot in the ground
which I did see enough to go who this
kid can he can do something really
really fluid runner not some stiff tall
track guy has great body control with
his speed has to be
the kickback shoulders and I saw plenty
of that because back shoulders are gonna
be a lot of his catches in football
because everybody's gonna go I'm not
gonna be fifty right right so make it it
will make him unguardable I wrote if he
can do that
let's see very quick fast I'm impressed
with the kid he's more polished better
all wide receiver that all-around wide
receiver than I expected
he's a taller version of a DeSean
Jackson or I wrote as my mind was going
or even better yet he's martavis Bryant
check the chalks ability to track the
deep ball is as good as it gets
biggest weakness is strength and
physicality can be affected by contact
while wanting routes a little bit not
alarming but it's still at least
concerning he will only get stronger I
wrote as he gets older and he could be a
little bit better at the line of
scrimmage
he can get off Jam but there was a few
cases where I saw people get up in his
chest and and it affected a little more
than you would like but if LSU needs a
big play they go to him big fan of this
kid has superstar potential good rat
runner could be can can be can be better
I guess I meant he can get better place
tough for a slender kid adjust to the
ball can teach the route running oh and
I wrote you can't teach this kind of
speed 21.8 yards per catch and i wrote
somewhere between 25 and 45 so you have
a head of Sun I do I have them five fix
out of sudden you really go Ridley more
shark Sutton yeah II think so love chart
I do like shark I do I like you guys are
freaked because I think guys like charkh
a lot of times two are gonna be only
better in the NFL like Odell coming from
there to where offenses know how to use
them more in their skill set yes focus
on getting in the ball where at times
you can get lost in the shovel but yes I
was very impressed with with all four of
these guys but yeah I know I don't even
know it's a weird year because there's
things that concern all like it does
bother me with DJ Sharky doesn't even
start some games they put other
receivers in there and I don't know why
what concerns you about sudden sudden is
the just the a little bit laksa Daisy
Cole
effort to get off the ball at times and
just some of the sloppiness of the
routes in general I think that would be
it but and then four more four more
again as the same thing just the rawness
of the route and running the fact that
you don't get to see much at all I mean
he can you get to see the least with him
oh really yeah you don't get to see I
mean as far as a route running ball in
his hands you don't need to know
anything more I mean it's it's special
he's gonna be able to outrun anybody and
really you just didn't get to see
anything Ridley you just you get to see
a lot of different routes and you go
there great and he runs him well and all
of that but you just go damn can we get
the ball in his hands like more than
twice a game man yeah that is Sims is
break down on the wide receivers in the
draft free-flowing the player Pro
personnel pro player personnel of the
citizen left coat pocket
what up all right that's it that's it
yeah that was a long one it was a long
one sorry we're gonna send you home this
weekend Sims is diving back into the
corner believe I'm doing it you're
shocked I'm shocked yeah I mean it's
just like I said at the start it's a
tough year
it's a tough year for the draft and we
are here to break it all down again
Miller Sims myself will be doing the
draft live on bleacher report so get
ready for that buckle up it's gonna be
weird we're gonna be doing a lot of fan
interaction and letting Sims and Miller
just go to town but for now for Sims
he's at homee for big Phil for fender
ik/fk man says good night have a great
weekend we'll holler at you on Monday
evening until then be well